Hey, this is really, really bizarre. This may
be one of the biggest, most jarring instances
of saying that A is actually B or that two
plus two equals five, or that, you know,
that double speak reminiscent of of George
Orwell. I told you yesterday that there was a
really important race Tuesday in Texas, his sixth
congressional district. It was a runoff where a
Trump endorsed Republican went against another
Republican, not endorsed by Trump. And the Trump
endorsee lost not by a crazy amount, but by about
six points. It was a there was no question that
they lost. And this was our first signal about is
Donald Trump going to be able to play kingmaker in
twenty, twenty two? Trump needs to successfully be
a kingmaker in twenty twenty two to have a better
shot at running in twenty twenty four and to
continue raising money and to continue at the head
of the Republican Party, et cetera, et cetera.
And now Trump is calling it a win. It's just it's
absolutely bizarre. There's a very interesting
article in Axios where Trump spoke to Jonathan
Swann on the phone. Listen to this. Trump's
advisers are angry at David McIntosh, president of
the conservative Club for Growth, for persuading
Trump to endorse a losing candidate in the special
election for Texas's 6th District. So, first of
all, it's blaming others why it matters. Susan
writes, Defeat Tuesday in a Republican runoff with
Navy veteran Jake Elzy dealt a blow to Trump's
aura of invincibility as a Republican kingmaker.
It's critical to his 2002 midterm endorsements
and continued hold on the Republican Party. Trump
advisers and allies have been ambivalent about the
club's advice and thought he should stay out of
this Republican on Republican contest. They take
the long view and are protective of his successful
record so far in Republican Party primary
endorsements. McIntosh did not respond to repeated
requests for comments. But this is the wacky part
Trump himself disputed. The result dented his
power. In a phone call with Axios on Wednesday,
the former president conceded McIntosh had pushed
him to support Wright but blamed Democrats for
ELSS victory. He also said he actually one day is
night. Black is white up is down. He said he won
because, right bested Elzy in the initial primary
and the runoff came down to two Republicans
he liked. So Trump is doing revisionist history.
He's saying, well, OK, I of these two Republicans,
I endorsed one and that Republican lost.
That might look like I lost, but no,
I actually like both the Republicans. So really,
it's a win. Now, of course, this is absurd because
if that's the way Trump saw it, then he shouldn't
have endorsed anybody. And this is an incredible
revisionist history. Trump then goes on to say, I
think this is the only race we've lost together,
Trump said of McIntosh and the Club for Growth
before catching himself midsentence on the word
lost. This is the only race we've this is not a
loss. Again, I don't want to claim it is a loss.
This was a win. The big thing is we had two very
good people running that were both Republicans.
That is the win. Trump is notorious for shifting
or refusing to accept blame for any failure,
whether as a businessman or as a politician.
The Club for Growth spent more than one million
dollars on the runoff, making it easily the top
outside spender. So what's interesting is you and
I are going to look at this and we are going to
evaluate it on the merits. But even losses, Trump
is calling wins and he's completely divorced from
reality. Maggie Haberman from The New York Times
sent an interesting tweet, which was the biggest
complaint. Republican candidates who might run in
twenty four have is that Trump gets a presumption
of strength. He doesn't actually have any more.
We don't actually know yet for long term
of Republican Party. But last night was an
unequivocal loss in a race he didn't need to step
into. Also, some conspiracies starting quickly.
Maggie Haberman writing. There are also some
interesting conspiracy theories going around right
now in Trump Land, blaming various Republican
senior elected for why Wright lost, for example.
Are people intentionally trying to diminish
Trump's clout? And the my reaction to that is,
of course, there are conspiracy theories starting
to spread. This is a loss for Trump. Let's see
what happens on the next one in building up this
picture of how influential he will or won't be.
He could also be influential, but in the negative
sense that he influences people to lose by giving
them an endorsement, it could end up being like
an anti endorsement. It's just too early to tell.